eh bien oui
merci
m
demain
beach vous êtes français excusez moi je
confonds un peu les deux langues
à bientôt les bonnes âmes aujourd'hui je
pense
quand tu cherches sait tout sur tout de
suite ça colle c'est agréable
ces moustiques
m
c'est
la douleur c'est un os de cachalot
bah ça se voit pas ce que ça sent le
foot de maisons de retraite au tour
parfait
voilà
les
koufos japon mais c'est bien que j'avais
un peu trop marché et oui j'avais le
temps peu biaudos in a été construit à
près de 40 ans commémorer la venue des
premiers japonais ah oui c'est bon à
savoir une info est plutôt sympa à voir
sortir dans tous les bons dînette
je me sens mieux
les ballets alors ça c'est le plus grand
phare du monde il mesure 800 800 mm donc
là notre guide nous a expliqué qu'il
fallait pas regarder avant d'arriver
pour un maximum de suspense donc je vais
mon chapeau c'est pas là bas c'est ça
c'est par là bas donc mon chapeau la
manière du caméléon pour ne rien voir
c'est pas la mecque pour ça cela c'est
baba hockey au magasin
oh
des enfants c'est vraiment sympa bon
allez vous arrêter m qui sonne pas du
tout ok bon celui-là by some tropiques
il sonne à hawaï
voilà
je possède
jet américain 16 heures dans ma tête il
est 4 heures du matin sur la plage et au
look eu deux norvégiens quant à mon
anglais il est plutôt moyen et donc exit
possibles doivent sa lettre de plage
oui c'est vrai combien
ce biais
que le mont saint michel
à
c'est vraiment bien
de mieux
les rangs c'est ici que cette arme notre
fabuleux voyage à hawaï
on skie devant la statue du duke il est
considéré comme un dieu vivant ici même
s'il est complètement décédé à 50 ans
les gens viennent y déposer des
couronnes de fleurs en guise d'offrandes
c'est lui qui a fait découvrir le surf
au monde entier un très grand monsieur
merci à toi duke à cette prochaine on
sera à los angeles pour la dernière
étape de notre tour du monde carrément
magistral
donc j'ai plutôt un mot à vous dire à la
semaine prochaine même si finalement
c'est plutôt une phrase région